you've probably heard the term acid used
in your everyday life but what we want
to do in this video is get a more formal
definition of an acid and particularly
focus on the one that is most typically
used although we'll see in future videos
that there's other fairly common
definitions of acids used as well beyond
the one that we're going to see here but
the one that we're going to focus on is
the bronsted-lowry definition the
bronsted-lowry definition of acids and
bases and this is a picture of bronsted
this is a picture of Larry and they came
up with this acid-base definition in the
1920s so we're going to do the
bronsted-lowry bronsted-lowry definition
definition of acids and bases so
according to them according to them an
acid an acid is a proton proton or
instead of writing proton we could
actually write hydrogen ion donor so why
is a proton and a hydrogen ion the same
thing well in the most common isotope of
hydrogen we would in its nucleus we
would find just a proton and no neutrons
and if it's neutral
you would have an electron buzzing
around jumping around in its orbital so
you would have its electron jumping
around in its orbital but if you were to
ionize it you're getting rid of its
electron so if you're getting rid of its
electron so if you're getting rid of
this all you're going to be left with is
a proton so that's why a proton and H+
is usually referring to the exact same
is referring to the exact same thing so
that's what an acid is so what would it
base be well you could imagine by this
definition a base a base would be a
proton would be a proton or you could
say a hydrogen ion acceptor acceptor so
let's make this a little bit more
tangible with some examples so one of
the stronger acids we know is
hydrochloric acid and let me let me draw
so it's a hydrogen having a having a
covalent bond having a covalent bond
with chlorine with chlorine with
chlorine right over there
and if we want to let's draw
chlorines lone pairs so outside of this
this will the the electron that is
contributing to this pair in the
covalent bond it also has it also has
three other lone pairs it also has three
other lone pairs just like that so if
you were to take hydrochloric acid place
it in an aqueous solution so it's in an
aqueous solution right over here and
actually an aqueous solution you'll see
this written like that that just means
it's in a solution of water so you could
write like this you could write a
hydrochloric acid in an aqueous solution
if you want to make it a little bit more
explicit you could say hey look this is
going to be around some water molecules
in its liquid form aqueous solution is
means it's it's dissolved in liquid
water so some water molecules in their
liquid form so this is a water molecule
whoops
water molecule right right over here so
an oxygen bonded to two hydrogen's and
sometimes you'll see it written like
this that it's in its liquid it's in its
liquid form well what do you think is
going to happen well I already said that
this is a strong acid right over here so
this is going to really want to donate
protons it's really one it's really
going to want to donate this hydrogen
but not let the hydrogen keep its
electrons so what's likely to happen
here
well the both of these electrons in this
pair are going to be grabbed by this
chlorine and then this hydrogen ion
because it's electron was grabbed well
this could be nabbed by some some water
molecule passing by remember in a real
solution you know just not like they
know what to do they're just all bumping
past to each other and based on how
badly they want to do things there these
reactions happen and so you could
imagine this lone pair right over here
well maybe it it's able to form a
covalent bond with this hydrogen and so
what's going to happen what's going to
happen and I'll draw it with just an
arrow because the this reaction
favorably goes very strongly goes to the
right because this is such a strong acid
well then you're going to be left with
you're going to be left with the
chlorine is now going to have it
it's three lone pairs that it had before
and then it also gate it also grabbed
these two electrons right over here it
also grabbed those two electrons right
over there so it gained an extra
electron it now has a negative charge it
is now the chloride anion so it has a
negative charge and what about this
water molecule
well this water molecule you have your
oxygen you have your hydrogen's you have
your hydrogen's but now you don't just
have two hydrogen's you grab two this
hydrogen right over here maybe I'll do
this hydrogen in a slightly different
color so that you could keep so that you
could keep track of it you have this
hydrogen right over there and this lone
pair this lone pair you can view it as
now forming this covalent bond
you had your other two covalent bonds to
the other two hydrogen's and then you
still have this lone pair right over
here you still have that lone pair
sitting right over there and what just
happened well this water molecule just
gained a proton it didn't this hydrogen
did not come with an electron so if you
just gained a proton you are now if you
were neutral before you are now going to
have a positive charge so what just
happened you put hydrochloric acid in a
water solution in an aqueous solution
this thing has donated a proton to a
water molecule and so what is the acid
and what is the base here well when we
look at the reaction this way we see we
see that this is the acid the
hydrochloric acid it's literally called
hydrochloric acid and here water is
acting as a base water is acting as a
base as you can see water can actually
act as an acid or a base
so water is acting as a base now you
might be saying okay this reaction goes
strongly to the right hey but like you
know I could imagine in certain
circumstances where chloride might
accept might accept a proton because it
has this negative charge and you would
be right this reaction goes strongly to
the right but once an acid has donated
its proton the thing that is left over
this is called a conjugate base and I'll
do the same color so this is the
conjugate
base of hydrochloric acid the chloride
anion conjugate conjugate base base of
hydrogen hydrochloric acid and this
right over here is the conjugate acid
because you could imagine this hydronium
ion this could under the right
circumstances donate protons to other
things donate a hydrogen without
donating electron to other things and so
this is actually a conjugate the
conjugate acid of h2o cons you get
conjugate acid of water of a water
molecule and as we'll see water can act
as an acid or a base but this gives you
a kind of a baseline of at least the
bronsted-lowry definition of acids and
bases and well actually one other thing
I want to add and some in some books
here so over here I say you put this in
an aqueous solution you're going to form
some hydronium sometimes you'll see it
written like this and I'll I'll just
write it a little bit a little bit
sometimes you will see it like this
so you have your hydrochloric acid and I
won't draw the details this time in an
aqueous solution so it's in a solution
of water and they'll just draw the
reaction going like this where they say
hey you're going to be left with you're
going to be left with some I some
hydrogen ions these protons and you're
going to be left with and you're going
to be left with and actually we could
say it's going to be in an aqueous
solution aqueous solution and you're
going to be left with some chloride
anions some chloride anions and it's in
an aqueous aqueous solution now this
isn't incorrect but it's important to
realize what they're talking about when
they're talking about these hydrogen
ions right over here we know that if you
have the hydrogen ions in an aqueous
solution they don't just don't hang out
by themselves they get grabbed by a
water molecule and they form hydronium
so it's much more I guess it's it's much
more close to the actual of what's
happening is if you actually talk about
hydronium forming as opposed to just the
protons because these protons in an
aqueous solution in a water solution
they're going to be grabbed by a water
molecule to form hydronium and that's
why I did it
the way this way up here